>> AND ITS OPTIONS GUYS IN THE
VALLEY NUMBER ONE FOR A
REASON. WELCOME BACK TO LAS
VEGAS NOW WITH MORE FAMILIES
TRAVELING AND GETTING TOGETHER
THIS HOLIDAY SEASON, MANY OF
US WILL BE GIVING MORE GIFTS
RIGHT LIFESTYLE EXPERT AMY
SEWELL IS HERE FROM BED BATH
AND BEYOND THE SPONSORS OF
THIS NEXT SEGMENT WITH IDEAS.
>> TO HELP YOU GIFT, HAPPIER.
I'M AMY SEWELL MOST OF US ARE
EXCITED ABOUT GATHERING WITH
FAMILY FOR THE HOLIDAYS.
>> AND EXPERIENCING THE JOY OF
SPENDING TIME TOGETHER AND
GIVING GIFTS IN PERSON THIS
YEAR FROM THE AFFORDABLE TO
THE LUXURIOUS BED BATH AND
BEYOND HAS HOME IN KITCHEN
ESSENTIALS THAT YOUR LOVED
ONES CAN ENJOY ANY TIME OF
FIRST THE FOOD IS ON YOUR LIST
WILL LOVE THE VERSATILE MENDED
DIGITAL AIR FRYER OVEN.
>> THIS IS AN AIR FRYER
CONVECTION OVEN TOASTER OVEN
ALL IN ONE, IT'S ESPECIALLY
GREAT FOR SMALL SPACES SINCE
YOU CAN ACTUALLY FLIP IT UP
AND START AGAINST THE
BACKSPLASH WHEN YOU'RE NOT
USING IT CAN SAVE SPACE AND
MONEY WITH A NEW SODA STREAM
BUSY ONE TOUCH SPARKLING WATER
MAKER.
>> INSTEAD OF BUYING SPARKLING
WATER YOU CAN TURN TAP WATER
AND A SPARKLING IN JUST A FEW
SECONDS FOR COFFEE LOVERS,
THIS IS FOR US OVER TO A
COFFEE AND ESPRESSO MACHINE IS
AN IDEAL GIFT, IT MAKES 4
DIFFERENT SIZES OF ESPRESSO OR
COFFEE, SO EVERYONE CAN ENJOY
BEING EVERY STEP. FOR WARM AND
COMFORTABLE GETS THE MODERN BY
THAT AND BEYOND EXCLUSIVE
STUDIO 3 BE COLLECTION HAS
SOMETHING FOR EVERYONE. THIS
CHUNKY KNIT THROW BLANKET
FEELS LIKE CURLING UP IN YOUR
FAVORITE SWEATER. THAT ALSO
MAKES IT PERFECT FOR SETTLING
IN WITH A CUP OF HOT COCOA TO
BINGE YOUR FAVORITE HOLIDAY
MOVIES, THIS GLASS JAR OR
MIDDLE BOWL CANDLES AND WITH
THE FRAGRANCES LIKE GREEN FOR
AND CEDAR MAKES FABULOUS
HOSTESS GIFTS AND STOCKING
STUFFERS. AFTER A LONG DAY OF
HOLIDAY ACTIVITIES ARE PLAYING
SPORTS PEOPLE CAN RELAX WITH
HIS SHARPER IMAGE POWER DEEP
TISSUE. MASSAGER WILL ALSO
LOVE THE SHARPER IMAGE COMBING
COZY ELECTRIC NOW THIS IS NOT
YOUR STANDARD ELECTRIC BLANKET
AS YOU CAN SEE IT'S ACTUALLY
COOK WHO LIKE ROUTE THAT HAS 3
THERAPEUTIC HEAT SETTINGS AND
FREE MASSAGE SETTINGS TO
RELIEVE MUSCLE ACHES AND
LOOSEN STIFF JOINTS YOU CAN
ALSO GIVE THE GIFT OF SLEEP
WITH THIS CAST FOR A WEIGHTED
BLANKET, HE'S NEVER TRIED ONE
OF THESE IT MAKES YOU FEEL
LIKE YOU'RE BEING WRAPPED IN A
BIG ANOTHER WAY TO STAY WARM
AND COZY IS TO WRAP UP WITH A
WARM TOWEL AFTER A SHOWER OR
TOWEL WARMERS FROM BED BATH
BEYOND NEW SPOT INSPIRED HAVEN
COLLECTION THIS AFFORDABLE
LINE ALSO HAS SUPER SOFT
TOWELS AND ROBES MADE FROM
100% ORGANIC COTTON OTHER
MODERN ESSENTIALS TO HELP YOU
TRANSFORM YOUR BACK INTO AN
OASIS. FINALLY YOU CAN GET THE
GIFT OF A CLEAN HOUSE WITH THE
SHARP CORDLESS FOR TEXT PRO
VACUUM, THIS COMBINES THE
POWER AND PERFORMANCE OF A
FULL-SIZE VACUUM WITH THE EASE
OF A CORDLESS STICK. IF YOU
HAVE SOMEONE ON YOUR LIST WITH
PETS. THEY WILL LOVE THIS
VACUUM BECAUSE IT HAS A
SELF-CLEANING BRUSH ROLE THAT
EASILY PICKS UP PET YOU'RE
DECORATING ENTERTAINING OR
SEARCHING FOR THE PERFECT GIFT
THAT WOULD BE ON TO MAKE
SHOPPING EFFORTLESS AND
>> THEIR IMPROVED MOBILE APP
OFFERS QUICK PRICE CHECKS
ORGANIZE YOUR COUPONS AND
OFFERS AND QUICKLY LOCATE
ITEMS IN THE STORE IN SELECT
STORES, YOU CAN EVEN SKIP THE
CHECKOUT LINE WITH THE APPS
NEW SCAN AND BY FEATURE IF YOU
HAVE SOME THINGS TO PICK UP AT
THE LAST MINUTE YOU CAN SHOP
ONLINE. GET FREE CURBSIDE AND
IN-STORE PICKUP WITHIN THE
WITH OPTIONS LIKE CONVENTIONAL
SHIPPING MORE EVEN SAME DAY
DELIVERY YOU CAN GET
EVERYTHING YOU NEED FOR THE
HOLIDAYS WHEN EVER YOU NEED
IT. FOR MORE INFORMATION GO TO
BED BATH AND BEYOND DOT COM
HAPPY HOLIDAYS.
>>>> BEST TO FOR SPONSORING THI
SEGMENT. I LOVE IT BACK TO